Evon you went to a film school in LA
mm-hmm but then you move back to the Bay
Area
after finishing why is that
I'll just go at Oxford no College and I
when I went there I was actually
undecided I tried out different studies
I went into philosophy economics
politics because I was trying to find
really well was my venue to really
affect the world I come from a family
that dedicated her life to it
so eventually around my junior year
Occidental College was cool because they
allowed you to take your time to figure
it out and I have to take some classes I
realize that film was really my my tool
and I grabbed onto that and so I stayed
in Italy obviously because it made sense
I'm here in LA you're studying film but
I started to become I got into the
camera world I was a cameraman for the
show called mundos that was part of
Telemundo's like Spanish MTV type thing
and it was fun I mean at 23 24 I was
filming everywhere concerts I was having
fun but you know you cannot become the
camera man that's what I kept being
called for and I wanted to write in
direct and you know I started being a PA
and there are a few independent projects
but being from the bay originally I knew
that there was a lot of being a
filmmakers access and knowing people and
I know more people in the bay and I
actually don't have a huge love for LA
in terms of living here so I was drawn
to go back and I knew a friend from high
school
his dad is a pretty well-known
documentary filmmaker and I went back to
to work on actually another doc of a
friend of mine just to actually edit and
I shot in Chile and edited that project
in the bay and being there I reconnected
with his friend we started doing music
videos reconnected with his dad and I
started working in documentaries because
I'm Berkeley is a mecca for documentary
filmmaking there's this building there
that has a ton of filmmakers a big
strong community and I ended up just
staying there and working in
documentaries for like four or five
years do you still come back to LA aside
for
this video here and and your screening
tonight or coming up yeah you have to
come back to LA I have a lot of friends
here that work in different styles of
music videos or some have their own
channels on YouTube and you know I still
work in production I have to compensate
not just being a director or writer but
I also shoot and yeah you have to come
back to LA every once in a while do you
think there's a difference in sound so
like cliche or pretentious but like
artistic expression in the Bay Area
versus here in LA is is there a
difference definitely I feel in the bay
at least I won't say everywhere outside
of LA but in the bay people are really
trying to focus on stories that mean
something to them personally and to
their community I think in Oakland
that's the thing if you watch the films
that are coming out of the bay they're
very much about local experiences and
and the town plays a role you know that
city that area or San Francisco in the
last black man you know it's a character
and you know there's been movies in LA
obviously they have that but a lot of
people here just trying to make mood
entertain they're trying to get a job
you know and I feel like in the bay
there's a lot more about it being an art
form and a form of expression to their
personal experience your bio says you
moved from Chile to the Bay Area in 1995
okay how do you think spending a good
chunk of the beginning of your life in
an area where a lot of artists were
silenced affected you need to want to
tell stories ah yeah growing up in LAN
Amir I grew up in like 8 different
countries in Latin America we moved
around a lot and I was always surrounded
by people who were exiled from Chile who
people people whose stories were for
silence it was dangerous to tell your
truth and I've realized more and more as
I as I grow older that that's definitely
my main motivation is to tell stories
that don't fit into the mainstream that
challenged the mainstream and they are
from voices will are usually
pushed back or silenced and yeah I
didn't realize at the time but a lot of
being an exile and fighting against a
regime that's trying to silence you
storytelling is kind of therapy
storytelling is yeah means of survival
and it means of organizing and so for me
filmmaking is that I I grab onto that
and I every project I work on it has to
address the society we live in has to
address people that are at the margins
and it has to be used as a tool to
change things I know you've done
documentaries on different journalists I
think and then Pedro Guerrero the
photographer so in an age where now
everyone can tell a story and it's
almost encouraged and everybody's
supposed to be a quote-unquote
influencer and whatever their little
niches how is that for you knowing you
grew up around a lot of people that were
fearful of saying anything how does that
work in your mind huh you know it's
interesting because my family is still
nervous about sharing their story
you know like for for my parents is even
hard to say what they went through and
so sometimes even now in an interview
you know how this is weird like
subconscious barriers sometimes to be
fully open about what you've been
through
and so in filmmaking it and when you
interview people I I really understand
that when you're interviewing somebody
and you're doing documentaries you're
almost like having a very vulnerable
moment and you have to really appreciate
that value that and respect that and the
same thing in fiction in our project
were the North Pole and different
projects I've worked on you you're
telling real people stories the North
Pole is about real people that we know
in our community so you have to really
acknowledge that that could be something
very vulnerable that could be something
very intimate and that you're exposing
it to the world and that's your
responsibility to do it right and I
think that that relationship to truth
into personal history is something that
I
a very careful bound respectful about on
a passenger question does yeah
absolutely
this is a little more of a lighter
question a movie that you were
embarrassed to admit that you love The
Princess Bride yeah
how did you find it out one of our
interns nice yeah it's a it's funny I'm
uh
I rarely allow myself to watch something
just for fun but I think it was really
fun and well made and memorable I mean
you go on told ya you know even watching
that movie before I knew English fully
like I remembered him and he was like
stuck with me and if a movie can do that
I think it's a big success but as a
filmmaker you say you don't see that
many films I don't why is that I think
two hours of your life is a long time to
spend doing anything and so I don't
consume film and that way or TV or
streaming I I like playing soccer I like
hanging out I like doing other forms of
art I like spending time with real
people and so I actually have a lot of
friends I trust their tastes and I know
my tastes and once I hear like a few
solid recommendations about something
I'll go and watch it
there's obviously certain things that I
have my eye on and like you know
anything that comes out of the bay I'm
gonna watch regardless anything that has
controversy and people like oh and it
deals with social justice even if most
people hate it I'm gonna watch it
because I have to have an opinion but
most things that like oh that was cool
I'm not gonna watch it like why so I'm
I'm pretty picky I guess and has to move
me you know it has to inspire me and so
if I'm gonna learn something I
definitely want to watch it and if or if
it's a commentary or something I care
about you know I want to have a
discourse with you know so why the North
Pole what why you launched crowdfunding
campaign or - this is your second series
second season for the North Pole okay I
definitely think it fulfills all my
requirements to watch it
it's gonna make you think if it has a
stance and I feel like almost anybody
can learn something from it and it's
based on real people's experience and in
our town in Oakland but it's very
relatable to a lot of cities in this
country I mean it's kind of like a
symbol of an experience that's happening
a lot in the country yeah did you see
something similar happen
growing up in Chile or whatever area you
grew up different years I know
gentrification wasn't a thing I grew up
with in Latin America but definitely you
know at the core of gentrification is a
class issue that's definitely at the
core of my experience in Latin America
you know and then in the world and
calling it what it is you know it's a
class struggle is it something that
nobody says in the show but in my
ideology that's what's happening it's a
identification it's a green issue and
rich people in the Bay San Francisco
being one of the richest cities in the
world and how that starts affecting the
surrounding areas and folks who aren't
have access to that capital that
experiences worldwide and then you know
that our second season is is about an
immigrant it's about an undocumented
immigrant and that story is based on a
friend of mine since high school who
actually used to lie to us he said he
was Puerto Rican and I took him like 10
years to reveal that he was actually
Salvadorian and so you know and I've
seen him go through his life with with
struggles who I at the time I didn't
understand why but you know he wanted to
be a fireman he wanted to be a airline
pilot and he was never able to achieve
that you know I was on the first plane
he flew small little Cessna and it was
scary
but that experience is similar to in my
childhood I was surrounded by X tiles
which are in essence people are forced
to emigrate and yeah those those
experiences of feeling like you don't
belong and you're not accepted and you
have to hide who you are it's definitely
part of like
my family's history in my community and
a close friend of mine who I I we use as
an inspiration it's a loose inspiration
but reduces as an inspiration for Benny
the main character whose idea was it to
begin writing the show it was initially
me Josh Healy and Darren Coulson got
together I mean me and Josh had been
working on a handful of other projects
that were kind of one-offs dealing with
you know we had one with boots Riley
about a climate justice March that
occurred we did one for that we did
another one dealing with immigration so
they were all kind of one-off pieces you
know we did want to against off fracking
a tag and Jerry Brown in a nice way and
but we kept talking about let's do
something bigger you know let's get into
characters let's tell a longer story and
so we all had that motivation so three
of us got together when a little mini
retreat and just started brainstorming
and coming up with characters and ideas
and planning out what would be this
world and that's working out it would
you write on your own and then bring it
back to the two other gentlemen and say
now the first season was the three of us
brainstorming together a lot Josh was
definitely the the lead writer and that
meant that we would all brainstorm and
him he would go and chop things down and
I would tell him he was wrong and then
he would tell me otherwise and that's
you know that's how he created the show
on different characters and the second
season
Darrin became just to produce certain we
were on the leads two of the leads
Dante Clark and Reina Maya and then it
became this four-person room and same
thing Josh being the showrunner and then
the four of us just you know getting
creative together
you wrote another screenplay American
Babylon mm-hmm which you won an award or
you wanted a grant me and what's the
screenplay about American Babylon takes
place in 2001 the summer of 2001 and it
follows 26 year-old exile from Chile I
don't know how he came up with it and he
he mostly just wants to ignore the world
around him and be happy and and be chill
and take care of his sick uncle who's a
extra Volusia nari from Chile who it's
kind of this if he recycles he builds
crosses for the church he stays that
he's kind of this hermit and uh the main
character also barters weed so he lives
in this underground economy but it's um
bartering and his girlfriend satya a
black girl from Oakland he also used to
Berkeley studies history
she's a activist he's organizing a march
so she's always pushing him to care and
to get involved in the world around him
back in 2001 you know Bush had just
stolen the elections and Oakland was up
in arms and there was huge marches
against globalization so the world was
very active and so my film is like
dealing with that world and pushing our
main character to care but he avoids it
until his uncle gets sick he can't
afford to take care of him he's forced
to switch from bartering to selling weed
kind of breaking his his mode of
operating in the world eventually the
march of the girlfriend organizes riot
police shut it down it's a peaceful
march but she gets hit and arrested and
taken away for a while and all these
things trigger the main character's
memories of his parents being killed in
a dictatorship in Chile and so these
these dreams last night mares start
reoccurring and pushing him and he ends
up kind of breaking and joining the
group of his girlfriend and they all
decide to take an action and because of
his history they decide to they pick a
day for an action based on a day that
started the dictatorship and chillin and
eventually it becomes an argument
between them about doing a violent
nonviolent action the girlfriend is
definitely about non-violence very much
like an MLK character and embodying that
ideology and the main character because
of his experience and his past cannot do
anything but do a violent act and it's
not about killing anybody but it's about
property destruction they pick a company
to had a history to his military coup
the US was heavily involved in a
military coup in Chile so the film is
like connecting these dots and
eventually they go into this it becomes
like a heist film and they go to do this
action there in the plaza in San
Francisco with two big screens on both
sides in the financial district they get
there's a snitch they get surrounded by
the police guns drawn and 9/11 happens
in the screens and that's the film and
it's it's based on real history a lot of
people don't know it but the
dictatorship in Chile occurred on
September 11th 1973 so all my life and
all Chileans lives 9/11 has been a day
that we that we mourn or you celebrate
depends on what side you're on but a day
for sure that marks or history and so
when 9/11 happened here I was a taxi
right here in LA I I still get chills
like how is that possible and they're
very similar events I mean there's
airplanes bombing the National Palace in
Chile and airplanes hitting a building
here on a Tuesday in the morning it's
just like really weird so it comes from
a place of me having to 9/11 is in my
life to kind of grapple and to address
the cycle of violence
you know like violence begets more
violence is the theme on my film and how
we won can I have a historical amnesia
and not acknowledge what's happened in
the past because if we do things will
keep happening and we need to learn how
to deal with these things and a
healthier way that's kind of my crazy
film how long did it take you to write
that
well the initial idea I mean the ending
came to me a few days after 9/11 I mean
I was like I have to connect these but
you know it's a long time ago and then
realistically two years ago two and a
half years ago I sat down and wrote my
first solid draft then I applied to this
a film rain and grant and I got a
screenwriting grant for that and since
then I've been you know I've done a few
drafts I went to this amazing lab called
scenic one on lab that takes place in
Mexico small talent scenes from the Sun
with mentors and 13 other filmmakers and
really like took my screenplay to a new
level
yeah so it's been solid two and a half
years really working hard at it yeah is
it hard for you to work on it is it does
it bring up it's good question memories
or sort of an anger I mean that's the
thing I had to realize that this lab is
that unconsciously I was definitely
protecting this character you know he's
not me but he's definitely somebody who
has a similar experience to me I had
both my parents thankfully so I don't
have the pain that he does but I still
was protecting him emotionally and a
screenplay in a movie you have to push
your characters to feel you know to go
rock bottom and so yeah I've had to open
up you know my own personal fears my own
personal traumas to allow this character
to go there and yeah the screenplays way
better because of that
you know you have to allow yourself to
to feel and to yeah go to your dark side
is that something you would recommend to
other writers don't don't protect your
main character as close as as they may
feel it absolutely I mean one of the
main lessons so the girlfriend is a
genius advice I got in you know there's
this my film is a story that has a huge
backstory that's not seen in the film
right his parents get assassin here
which is like the biggest emotionally
back story you can have character losses
as parents right
so an equivalent to that you have to
balance that out with the present film
otherwise why are you telling the
present not the past
and so something just as emotional needs
to occur in your present in the film it
needs to happen to this character that
pain needs to happen to this character
how do you achieve that you know how do
you achieve a trauma of a past to affect
the present so I'm not doing this but I
recommendation or a logical deduction of
that it's like I have to kill the
girlfriend all right like somebody has
to die uncle I said I somebody has to
kill but even if you're not gonna make
that choice as a writer because you
don't feel it's right you have to try it
and by doing so by pushing to the edge
like killing somebody and one of your
characters you're gonna learn what you
need to do what you miss what what you
can gain from that it kind of experiment
and so I highly recommend when you're
dealing with highly emotional things -
yeah push it to the limit not as a just
a gimmick but to learn what this does to
your character into your story and they
helped me a lot to kill her for like
three days she comes back to life
now she'll go down like I said I I
practice I worked out the film in a way
what happens if she does get killed you
know like what does that mean to the
care what does that trigger and how that
can I I don't want to how does that how
can you achieve a symbolic death in a
way you know that's what I had to do is
figure out a way that she in a way dies
Vanessa
so you've done work with American
masters mm-hmm
PBS yeah yeah and if someone comes to
you let's say 60 70 years from now a
young filmmaker as you've done with thon
was it Pedro Guerrero or different other
stories they've done and they say we
want to do a movie about your life hmm
well what do you what do you envision
that the core takeaway being I realize
that's that's many years in the future
but if somebody said we want to spend
time with you we want you to turn over
your photographs or your different
images and be vulnerable in front of the
camera and what do you think the the the
core message in the movie would be um
well ideally it's sacrificing dedicating
yourself to use whatever I use art I use
film but dedicating your life to
effecting change I think you focus on my
childhood my parents are a huge
influence in that in the world I grew up
in was people sacrificing their life to
you know overthrow a dictatorship I was
killing and disappearing people and then
you know this kid moving to the u.s. to
a time with real no movements in
comparison to Latin America and no solid
cost to grab on to and figuring out how
to continue that legacy and hopefully I
can be an inspiration in film and
general and artists to go back to a lot
of people have done in the past using
film as a much more poignant and
activating tool to transform society
ideally that would be my legacy but I
have to create a few more things too and
learn I think continue learning how to
affect people emotionally and inspire
them to change
yeah I know hey - Barry and that whole
flower child generation up there in the
Bay Area was very much about you know
fighting for different causes I don't
remember Generation X when I was up
there being into that I think it seems
like there's definitely a renewed
interest
well the 80s were tough Fila 80s is one
day one and they shut it down and made
it totally unrealistic to have dreams
you know and you just have to make money
and I think that's where we've been
we've been where our generation I'm born
in 1984 generation it's like Oh dreaming
and thinking big and trying to change
the world that doesn't work you know
that's what we've been told and I feel
like the 80s were definitely about you
know making money and in 90's and
everything in pop culture still is a lot
about that but there is a switch I mean
there is there's a shift happening where
we need to transform our value system
you know and stop it's not money over
people and I think art needs to start
change that even more and start telling
stories that reimagine our future and
change how we interact with each other
and reminders of the past I mean we have
to go back and I mean Hollywood there's
a lot of people who are blacklisted who
are telling stories that are very
different from the mainstream and that's
you know you can't discount that you
can't say oh that just happened
that was on purpose people were silenced
and taken out of the biggest most
powerful influential tool in the world
which is making movies and so where are
those voices now and how do we repair
that lack of participation